小野郎
I-I-in-don't-know-what。
嗨好久不见
欢迎回到第三杯别空。
我是Zen
炭火还暖着
你看我如约而至
接下来邀请你
我们一起继续
这场咖啡的旅途
第一季我们从一只跳舞的羊开始。
走了很远的路
埃塞俄比亚的高原。
卖家的总督府
梵蒂钢的宫殿
维也纳的维城
海地的众之缘
印尼的龙子
还有芳芳
还有印尼的龙子
还有芳芳太和巴尔扎克的书桌。
8集8个故事
我们从一杯咖啡
回弹到了
500年的人类史。
第二季我想要
换个方向
不再沿着时间之河游荡。
而是往旁边走走看。
这一季的主题是
咖啡与文化的变行纪。
咖啡从埃塞俄比亚出发。
飘过洪海，跃过大西洋，穿过太平洋，去了很多地方。
但每到一个地方，它都会变形。
一杯咖啡被当地人重新理解，重新使用，重新定义。
日本把它变成了安静的吃茶店。
古巴把它变成了革命的燃料。
美国则把它变成了萤幕上的橙色沙发。
这一季，我们就聊聊这些变形。
而今天这集节目的元气是我在6月底整理波克素材时看到的一则附告。
传奇的美剧导演 James Burroughs在睡梦中暗象离世。
想念85岁
James Burroughs从业的50多年，指导了超过1000级的电视剧。
手握11座艾美奖。
这其中就包括影响了我整个青春的老友绩。
欢乐酒吧，生活大爆炸。
还有破产姐妹，威尔与格雷斯，欢乐一家亲等等。
那接下来，我们就从美剧起程。
我先抛一个小小的问题出来。
你脑海中对咖啡馆的印象有多少是从海外的电视剧里来的。
那个橙色沙发，那杯永远都喝不完的大杯拿铁。
还有那个永远在八台后面擦杯子的老板。
这些画面到底是现实影响了电视，还是电视塑造了现实。
这一集我们就走进萤幕上的咖啡馆。
看看他们从哪里来，去了哪里。
以及他们如何反过来塑造了我们对一家咖啡馆的期待。
1982年，NBC播出了一部新剧，场景非常简单。
一间名字叫做Cheers的波士顿小酒吧？
有深色的木头，砖墙和朴素的八台。
整个空间并不精致也不时尚，但非常温暖。
欢乐酒吧的故事全都发生在这里。
来这里的每一个人都互相认识，都知道彼此的名字。
距离的人物来自各行各业，有酒保服务员，有游地员，还有心理医生。
他们大致都有一个共同点，工作不理想，家庭不幸福。
但至少他们有一个可以回去的地方。
走进酒吧，大家就成了嘻笑怒骂的一家人。
主题曲里有一句歌词，我每次听都有一点感动。
Sometimes you want to go where everybody knows your name。
有时候，你想去一个所有人都知道你名字的地方。
这句话精准的概括了第三空间的核心功能。
被看见，被记住，被接纳。
Cheers是酒吧，不是咖啡馆。
剧中人喝的是啤酒，不是拿铁。
但这其实也不重要。
重要的是空间的功能，一个可以反复回去的。
有固定座位和熟悉面孔的地方。
Cheers的常客们，总是坐在吧台的固定位置。
和老友纪历Santra Park那张橙色沙发一样，是一种领地感。
剧中的角色，会为了谁的座位而争吵。
只恰恰证明，当一个公共空间有了固定座位。
他就已经成了你生活的一部分。
欢乐酒吧播了11年，整整275集。
他最先定义了美国人对第三空间的想象。
只不过在那个年代，那个空间是酒吧？
You wanna be where you can see。
Our troubles are all the same。
You wanna be where everybody knows your name。
You wanna go where people know。
People are all the same。
You wanna go where everybody knows your name。
1994年，Friends老友纪开播。
6个住在纽约的年轻人，经常聚在一家叫做Santra Park的咖啡馆里。
Santra Park是虚构的，在距离他位于纽约是格林威之村。
他的名字，结合了曼哈顿区的中央公园Santra Park。
和咖啡树与Perk，P-E-R-K。
Perk本身是一种诞生于法国的叫做Perk later的圣律式咖啡壶。
他是这个词的口语话缩写。
这种煮咖啡的方式在改革开放前的中国也非常流行。
因此，Perk有煮咖啡的含义。
而于此同时，Perk Hub也有振作精神的意思。
所以这个双关的命名本身就暗示了咖啡不只是饮料。
它是一种能让人振奋的东西。
据说Santra Park在最初差点不存在。
不出方觉得咖啡馆太小资。
太New York。
建议改成简易餐厅。
说句玩笑话
如果当年这个建议被采纳。
我们今天甚至有可能不会在咖啡馆里去约会。
写稿和发呆了
不过老友记得主创们坚持采用咖啡馆的方案。
他们想要一个不属于任何人家。
不属于办公室的地方。
一个纯粹的第三空间。
于是就有了那张橙色的沙发。
那个永远在吧台后面擦杯子的咖啡是gancer。
还有那杯永远喝不完的打杯拿铁。
网上有发烧油统计过一个数据。
老友记全剧的236集中。
六位老友一共喝了1154杯咖啡。
平均每集将近5杯。
这不是在喝咖啡
这是把咖啡当成了背景音乐。
但仔细回想剧情
我似乎也不会总看到他们在喝一口咖啡。
大部分时候他们只是手里端着杯子。
然后聊天吵架谈恋爱。
咖啡是道具
但正是这个道具定义了整个空间的气质。
咖啡
说起在三车perk发生的名场面。
那个太多了
我想要分享两个我最喜欢的角色的片段。
有一天招仪和约会对象在一间餐馆吃饭。
因为这个女生吃了一口她的薯条。
招仪便大声说了一句。
joy doesn't share food。
之后再也不见
回到三车perk。
招仪面对想要吃一口她松饼的肉。
再次打喊
joy doesn't share food。
joey doesn't share food。
这句话后来成了老友及史上被引用最多的台词之一。
但我觉得最动人的。
是joey后来几次把食物递给了她真正在乎和需要的人的珍贵时刻。
因为真正的分享不是我不能分享。
而是我愿意为你打破我不能分享的规矩。
还有一个场景
虽然不搞笑
但在我心里分量很重。
不知道你是否还记得smelly cat。
这是一首菲比写给一只臭臭的流浪猫的歌。
然后唱编公司说要把这首歌商业化。
但最后的录音室版本却用了声音替唱。
唱的流行好听
编曲也很精致
只有在MTV中才用到了菲比的形象。
这首歌失去了菲比赋予她的灵魂。
而且菲比很同情那位。
没有机会露脸的替唱女生。
她觉得这个女生就像歌曲里面的流浪猫一样。
因为不够漂亮而无人领养。
菲比无法接受唱编公司这种行为。
拒绝了一次成名的机会。
最后她回到三车perk。
重新唱了那个不完美的自己的版本。
然后她的朋友们
Rose, Rachel, Monica, Chandler, Joey。
坐在橙色沙发上
听她唱那首关于一支美人要的流浪猫的歌。
那个场景对我意味着什么？
她意味着一个不完美的人。
在一个不完美的地方。
唱了一首不完美的歌。
被一群不完美的人接纳了。
三车perk之所以成为传奇。
不是因为她的咖啡有多好喝。
也因为她的咖啡有多好喝。
她的咖啡有多好喝。
也不是因为她的沙发有多舒服。
而是因为那里受留了所有人的不完美。
还有一个我特别想提的细节。
三车perk的背景版演员。
国外有很多老友记粉丝。
他们会反复刷具
寻找那些有趣的群众演员。
有一幕是这样的
一位惊发的女生坐在咖啡馆窗边。
在喝了一口咖啡之后。
竟然开始咀嚼咖啡杯。
她可能只是无聊
也可能只是饿了
或许只是想给自己找点事做。
但她咀嚼咖啡杯的那个瞬间。
却让三车perk变得无比真实。
因为一个完美的干净的。
所有人都体面的咖啡馆是虚假的。
但一个群演在没人注意的时候。
拒绝咖啡杯那种无聊那种松散。
那种不需要维持形象的松弛感。
却是真实的
老友记最厉害的地方。
不是她创造了三车perk。
是她让全世界的人相信。
自己都需要有一个三车perk。
后来大家都知道了。
全球各地出现了无数的三车perk主题咖啡馆。
粉丝们坐在复刻的橙色沙发上。
点一杯咖啡
仿佛走进了那部剧。
这不仅仅是对一部剧的致敬。
更是对一种生活方式的渴望。
请你想想在老友记之前。
有多少人会约朋友去喝一杯咖啡呢？
在老友记的最后一集。
Monika和Chaneler准备搬去郊区。
大家把钥匙留在空荡荡的旧公寓。
此时Rachel提议。
一起去喝杯咖啡
她说 we got some coffee。
Chandler用她标志性的语气。
说了全句的最后一句台词。
sure where。
好啊去哪儿喝呢？
ok should we get some coffee。
sure
where
这是一个明知故问的梗。
她用这句话打破了伤感。
却提醒了所有人
他们永远都会在一起喝咖啡。
不论在Santra Perk还是其他地方。
与朋友去咖啡馆的风潮。
或许很大程度上
是被Friends这部剧引爆的。
joke your road。
the love lives the way。
it's like you're always stuck in second gear。
when it hasn't been your day。
you're with your mom。
and we've been all year。
but i'll be there for you。
when the road starts to grow。
i'll be there for you。
like i've met the ladies before。
但Santra Perk不是唯一的。
老有机之前和之后。
每距离还有很多咖啡馆。
每一个都在用不同的方式。
回答同一个问题
我们为什么需要这样一个地方。
先说一说欢乐一家清理的咖啡Nervosa。
有人把它翻译成神经咖啡馆。
这部剧是Cheers欢乐酒吧的衍生剧。
1993年开播和老有机几乎同时。
主角Freezer Korean最早出现在欢乐酒吧的第二集。
是一名心理医生
后来他离开博士顿。
也离开了Cheers酒吧？
一句到了西雅图
开始了新的生活
这篇人决定Freezer来到了新的城市。
依然需要一个非工作。
非家庭的场所
而西雅图以咖啡馆闻名。
所以就有了咖啡Nervosa。
Nervosa和Santra Park的区别是什么呢？
Santra Park是老有机里年轻人的社交场所。
Nervosa是中产阶级知识分子的第三空间。
Freezer和他的弟弟Nails两个极度讲究。
极度神经制的知识分子。
坐在Nervosa里讨论红酒。
讨论古典音乐 心理学。
还有他们年迈父亲的奇怪的行为。
第一季的最后一集。
是我觉得特别有意思的一集。
他的名字叫做My Coffee with Nails。
Freezer和他的弟弟Nails从头到尾。
都在咖啡Nervosa里对话。
整集没有离开过那间咖啡馆。
像极了一部舞台剧。
两个人一边被剧情中的各路人舞打断对话。
一边讨论一个看似简单又深刻的问题。
Are you happy?。
你快乐吗？
有一个好笑的插曲。
对咖啡极度挑递的Freezer。
从点单开始就调难服务员。
他让服务员重新做了整整四杯咖啡。
第一杯咖啡不满意。
是因为它不是低音咖啡。
第二杯咖啡又因为没有用低纸牛奶。
第三杯咖啡又因为里边有放肉桂粉。
直到聚集的莫尾
所有人都离开了这间咖啡馆。
最后一杯咖啡被从头到尾。
听他们聊天的服务员端上来。
服务员说
现在你开心了吗？
Freezer回答说。
大体来说是的
我很开心
DCAF
non-fat milk no cinnamon in sight。
现在
你开心了吗？
你知道吗？
在最大的选择之中。
是的 我说我是
在最后Freezer终于回答了那个。
简单又深刻的问题。
你快乐吗？
他说我很快乐
不过在片尾曲的彩蛋里。
Freezer又从咖啡里喝出了什么东西。
他把服务员重新喊来。
再做了一杯新的咖啡。
直到现在我的脑海里。
一直都有这样一个场景。
两个穿着昂贵西装。
和精致皮鞋的心理医生。
坐在咖啡馆
整集都在讨论
你是否快乐这样一个话题。
但直到最后他们聊的。
都是生活的困惑
至于是否快乐
其实并没有答案
而反复出现的咖啡。
还有咖啡Navosa的店员。
成了这对兄弟整个下午。
唯一的观众
接下来还有
宋非正传里的Monks Cafe。
Monks外表是纽约曼哈顿。
哥伦比亚大学附近的一间。
叫做Tom's Restaurant的店面。
Jerry, George, Elaine, Kramer。
四个人经常坐在卡座里。
是卡座
他们常常聊一些
看似毫无意义
却有好笑也值得思考的话题。
Monks这间咖啡馆。
看似是一个
反第三空间的第三空间。
它不温暖不治愈
也不提供任何情感支持。
它只是一个地方
但正是这个
只是一个地方的场所。
成了四个怪人
反复回去的基地
有时候人们不需要。
喜欢一个第三空间。
需要的其实只是
它在哪里
好
在后来
还有杰尔摩女海里。
经常出现的Luke Steiner。
单身母亲Laurela。
和女儿Rory
几乎每天都去
他们家里虽然也有咖啡机。
但还是会走过去
跟小餐馆的老板Luke。
要一杯咖啡
这是为什么？
因为Luke Steiner。
不仅仅是一个
喝咖啡的地方
它是开始新一天的地方。
Laurela和Rory在那里。
和邻居聊天
和朋友争吵
和Luke调情
咖啡只是借口
真正的目的
是被欲情人包围着。
然后开始一天的生活。
最后我想说一个
不太一样的美剧
Twin Peaks 双风。
大卫临棋的这部剧里。
FBI探员Cooper。
是一个无法离开黑咖啡。
和枯矮银豪派的人。
他所在的双风镇这个地方。
居民们也几乎都去一间。
叫做Double R Diner的地方和咖啡。
在第一季第七集中。
Cooper和警长Harry。
来到Double R Diner办案。
在这里做服务员的Sally。
问他们是否要喝一杯咖啡。
警长说
他们还有任务
应该出发了
但Cooper笑了笑。
淡定的拍了拍
警长的肩膀说了一段。
我至今难忘的话
把他翻译成中文就是。
Harry
我要告诉你一个很小的秘密。
每天
就一次
给自己一个礼物
不要计划
不要等待
就让它自然发生
可以是在男装店
买一件新衬衫
可以是在办公室的椅子上。
打个顿
也可以
是两杯美食
滚烫的黑咖啡
Double R Diner和前面。
所有的咖啡馆都不一样。
这里不温暖
不治愈
也不搞笑
它是一个悬疑的
诡异的
充满了秘密的地方。
但Cooper一旦有机会。
还是会去
因为在一个陌生的。
危险的
无法信任任何人的地方。
一杯好咖啡
是唯一可以确定的东西。
Cooper喝下了一口咖啡。
然后说
Nothing like a great cup of black coffee。
全天下最棒的东西。
就是一杯好喝的黑咖啡。
你看
从Cheers到Central Perk。
从Norosa到Monks。
从Looks到Double R。
每一个第三空间都不一样。
酒吧？
咖啡馆
餐馆
简易餐厅
温暖的
搞笑的
神经质的
诡异的
但他们共享同一个功能。
一个所有人
都可以反复回去的地方。
请我们从美剧的情境中走出来。
一起聊聊
为什么美国的第三空间。
在十年间
从酒吧？
变成了咖啡馆
Cheers开播于1982年。
Central Perk老友记。
出现在1994年。
这十二年里
发生了什么？
我认为
首先是咖啡文化
恰好在90年代
大范围兴起
1966年
Peace Coffee在伯克里开业。
1971年
新巴克在西雅图开业。
到90年代
新巴克
已经开始在美国境内。
大范围扩张
咖啡不再是提神的饮料。
它正逐渐变成了一种。
新潮的生活方式
其次
都市中的
年轻人的社交习惯。
也巧然发生了转变。
80年代的年轻人。
选择去酒吧？
但随着健康意识的上升。
以及咖啡因
比酒精
更适合白天的日常。
因此
越来越多的年轻人。
开始选择去咖啡馆。
最后
也是最不容忽视的一点是。
随着时代的进步
女性
在空空空间中的
存在感变了
Cheers的酒吧文化。
本质上
依然是一个男性空间。
尽管剧中有女性角色。
但酒吧的主场
还是男性的
而咖啡馆却不一样。
他一开始
就是中性的
一个人
不论性别
他都可以
独自去咖啡馆
发呆
看书
找人聊天
都一定不会有人觉得奇怪。
所以从这个角度看。
去咖啡馆这件事
是全民性的
公共空间的转移
如果从当时
人们的生活状态来想。
我觉得在八九十年代开始。
更多人正在从
无奈的逃离生活
到积极的讨论生活过渡。
Cheers里
人们去酒吧？
是为了逃避
逃避工作
逃避家庭
逃避自己的问题
他们坐在吧台前
喝一杯
抱怨点有的没的
或者什么都不想
Santra Perkley的人物。
去咖啡馆
是为了讨论
讨论工作
讨论爱情
讨论自己的人生选择。
他们坐在橙色沙发上。
喝一杯咖啡
不论想起什么？
都可以聊
从酒精到咖啡因
从麻木到清醒
从沉默到清素
美国的第三空间
其实是完成了一次。
文化转型
这让我想到了一个有意思的问题。
我们为什么总是需要一个。
可以讨论生活的地方。
或许是因为生活太复杂了。
一个人怎么也想不明白。
我们都需要一个空间。
不是家
不是办公室
而是可以和几个信任的人。
把那些想不明白的事说出来的地方。
其实说出来也不一定有答案。
但至少我们知道
自己并不是唯一一个。
对生活有无穷无尽的困惑的人。
让我们再往根源去想想。
第三空间
为什么必须存在
Cheers和Sancher Perk。
有一个共同点
他们都不是精致的地方。
Cheers是蓝灵酒吧？
老旧的木质疤台上。
永远都有划痕
Sancher Perk。
橙色沙发
又旧又破
老师
却神经质的咖啡师gancer。
似乎永远都在查同一个被子。
但我反而觉得
正是因为这种不精致。
让他们变得更容易清静。
回到我们如今的生活。
我们到处都有很多。
看似精致的社交空间。
设计赶爆棚的咖啡馆或酒吧？
需要提前一周约的小众餐厅。
还有数不尽的拍照好看。
但坐一会儿
屁股就会疼的想要离开的地方。
这些地方很美
但他们不提供归属感。
去一次拍拍照
发发朋友圈
然后很有可能
我会再去第二次了。
但Cheers和Sancher Perk。
人们每天都可以去。
不需要理由
不需要消费额度
更不需要拍照
我们在第一季提到的。
社会学家雷奥尔登伯格。
在The Great Good Place。
这本书里反复强调。
第三空间的中立性。
他说第三空间是建立在。
Neutral Ground这个中立的地面之上的。
所有人都处于一种。
社会平等的状态
任何人可以来
也可以走
可以说话
也可以沉默
这个人可以是任何人。
也可以谁都不是
在这个中立的地面之上的空间里。
我们不必扮演任何社会角色。
不是某某公司的什么员工。
或领导
不是某某人的配偶。
也不是某某孩子的家长。
我只是我自己
你也只是你自己
一个喝咖啡
或者喝酒的人
坐在那里
什么都不用去证明。
村上春树的挪威的森林里。
都边撤在回答小林绿子。
关于是否喜欢孤独的提问时。
说了一句话
我一直记得
哪里会有人喜欢孤独。
不过是不喜欢失望吧？
这种既渴望连接
又害怕受伤的矛盾心理。
恰好是我20岁
出头那个时候的心理状态。
而第三空间
刚刚好
可以帮助我们避免这种失望。
你不需要从任何人那里。
得到什么？
只是坐在那
旁边是一群和你一样。
作者的人
这恰恰是一种
不所取任何东西的陪伴。
Cheers主题曲的歌词非常好。
Sometimes you want to go。
where everybody knows your name。
有时候你想去一个。
人人都知道你名字的地方。
这里不是人人都爱你。
也不是人人都需要你。
仅仅是
人人都知道你叫什么？
回到开头那个问题。
到底是现实影响了电视。
还是电视塑造了现实。
答案也许你早就知道。
他们是互相塑造的。
Cheers拍摄于1980年代。
那个年代
美国人确实去酒吧？
但Cheers让酒吧？
作为第三空间这个概念。
变得更清晰
更令人向往
老友记拍摄于90年代。
那个年代咖啡馆
也确实在兴起
但Sancher Perk让咖啡馆。
作为第三空间这个概念。
变成了全球性的文化想象。
今天当你走进任何一间。
咖啡馆
不管在北京上海
东京还是纽约
你都能看到Sancher Perk的影子。
一个靠窗的座位
一张可以坐一下午的沙发。
还有一个
不会催你走的服务员。
这些不是偶然
他们是老友记和Sancher Perk。
留给这个世界的异产。
第二季的第一集
我们一起聊了聊
美剧萤幕上的咖啡馆。
接下来我们会继续走。
走去日本京都的
一条不起眼的巷子。
那里有一家
叫六要社的池茶店。
它开了三代人
快一百年了
那里的咖啡
和Sancher Perk完全不同。
深空的豆子
没有冲
没有拉花
没有WiFi
但功能是一样的
一个你可以反复回去的地方。
我们还会走到哈瓦娜。
看看上个世纪50年代。
古巴革命前后的咖啡馆。
那里没有橙色沙发。
没有gancer。
只有潰伐
炎热
和一杯在革命中
活下来的黑咖啡
我们依然会回到美国。
去看看格林威治村。
民谣舞台上的爆破地轮。
我们还会去看看
文学绘画电影
建筑
和广告史上里的咖啡。
最后
我们一起走回中国。
看看从清朝末年的。
翻轨茶
到今天
遍布街巷的瑞幸
最后
再次欢迎你
回到第三杯别空
这个虚拟的第三空间。
接下来的第二季
没有殖民的血色
没有龙中的猫
没有咖啡鹰的分子氏。
但有温度
有画面
有我们曾经在萤幕上。
在书里
在某个下午
与咖啡相遇的瞬间。
如果你喜欢第三杯别空。
欢迎订阅
如果你想和我聊些什么？
也欢迎留言
炭火还暖着
杯子别空
我们下期见
是现在来的
特别是我
而原因是很清楚
是因为你
你就是我